I had some health issues when I was
younger with my heart I am grateful many
mornings I wake up I say spiel time I've
been happy rich and I've been happy poor
happy rich is better successful people
and wealthy people have a subtle
distinction they don't look at price
they look at worth need motivation watch
a top ten with belief nation was that
belief nation it seven I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and show in today's lessons from a man
who went from being born in a
middle-class family to building one of
the most successful financial services
company in the world and being one of
the top motivational speakers on the
planet he said my lat and here's my take
on his top ten Ruth's success vol 2
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one grow you I don't believe in faking
it till you make it
you know what entrepreneur is amiss
right it's the greatest self-discovery
process in the history of mankind in it
you learn more about yourself what you
don't know your resiliency how tough you
are what your weaknesses are by being an
arch where it's probably the greatest
self-discovery program in the history of
the world it's also this it's the
greatest self-improvement program with
the highest compensation package
possibly attached to it - that's what
entrepreneurs there is a
self-improvement program with massive
compensation package attached to it and
that's why too many of you are too
focused on growing your company and not
focus enough on growing you because your
company will never ever exceed your
identity or your vision for it you got
to grow you because what'll happen when
it starts to grow you'll start making
unconscious mistakes to shrink it making
bad calls getting weak getting lazy
making mistakes you're all nodding
because you've all done it because at
some point your business got ahead of
you it will never exceed your identity
and your vision because if the company
catches your vision the company catches
your identity you're dying
rule number two be in a state of
gratitude I'm grateful that I have the
money for the plane ticket still it's
odd it's odd how small things I love big
things I look up in my jet but it's I
make sure that I'm grateful for what
most people will think are small things
and I really am like I'm I had some
health issues when I was younger with my
heart I am grateful many mornings I wake
up my day starts with gratitude I'm
awake many many mornings and so that's a
centerpiece of my life it's sort of it's
odd because I have all these things in
my head when I was a kid like at
gratitude is sort of the antidote for
everything not good in my life rule
number three care about people what
would you say is your greatest asset
skill I love people man I care about
people I sincerely do and so whether
that's yeah I mean I want to help you I
want to people say how do you get back
to all these people on social media I
care you know you and I have a lot that
in fact like I really I I my intent is
good man I want to I want to make a
difference in the world you know we're
all put here for a reason and like
it sounds hokey like I've made a lot of
money like I'd like to make more money
but it's not really a driver for me
right you've got a bunch of homes and
that feel that need it's not and it
doesn't it's not long-lasting no
material thing I've ever acquired was as
cool as I thought it would be it's go
for a week or two and exactly alright
now what know what right it's empty and
so by the way I think everybody should
have a jet if they can have one
everybody ought to have a unicorn on
there waterfall everybody out of
oceanfront like I've been I say spiel
time I've been happy rich and I've been
happy poor happy rich is better don't
let anybody tell you happy rich ain't
better than happy poor trust me it's
better you and money's a magnifier if
you're a really good person you get a
bunch of money it's probably gonna
magnify your generosity and kindness and
your patience and if you're a chrome uh
gin and mean and hurt people money's
gonna magnify that too
so I'd rather have a bunch of money yeah
hands down right but it's not something
that drives me in my life it doesn't
have a filmy rule number four stop
negotiating the price when I was poor
everywhere I went
flip the price tag hood what's it cost
what's it cost what's it cost what's it
cost I was constantly negotiating the
price for everything in my life you do
that when you come to a place of
scarcity of being poor successful people
and wealthy people have a subtle
distinction they don't look at price
they look at worth is this worth it
if you're constantly looking at the
price tag you'll eventually relent
you'll eventually give in stop
negotiating the price it's a freeing
experience to totally commit when you
totally commit to a relationship to a
business to your fitness to your faith
it's a free powerful it's almost like
removing kryptonite from your life when
you totally commit can you do that the
people around you it's costing too much
it's costing too much and you're gonna
and maybe it's costing too much you guys
are going no it's worth it it's not the
price it's the worst it's a subtle
distinction in your life rule number
five have persistence
you've been very successful as an
entrepreneur have you always been
successful you just said the word an
entrepreneur and always successful so
you know
I try to tell everybody nobody I haven't
met one entrepreneurs oh oh yeah
everything I have ever done work go over
there lying it read oh well they're not
an entrepreneur they've inherited
something or mostly right because if you
if you're an entrepreneur you have not
always been successful right so come
Steve Jobs down all the way and so I've
had successes and then I'll go backwards
so what like most entrepreneurs there's
false start after false start after
false are so I would get it going and it
would go backwards I'd save some money
then I'd blow it you know my business
would grow then it would shrink and so
no I've had I've had tons of different
financial events happened in my life and
actually actually after people thought I
was pretty successful I'd become a
millionaire about 26 years old I'd
become a millionaire I was making a
million dollars a year and I ended up
losing it all and it ended up I lost a
home I lost a car I ended up moving into
an apartment I was newly married I'll
never forget this I remember because
this oceans out there we're looking at
it right now and I remember honestly
defining moment you I had everything
turned off you have power turned off and
still survive one thing I learned you
don't want your water turned off and we
had the water cut off so I'm lives here
newlywed my new and six weeks married we
end up still with you she's still with
me she's well around here somewhere yeah
she's with me that's some what's in
common I know we do both high school and
the same thing with her with her with
her wives and long story short we had to
go every morning out of the apartment go
down to the pool and shower outdoors and
you bring our toothbrush it was just
shameful for me rule number six keep the
promises you made to you the key to self
confidence is really simple
and it is this is absolutely I've
trained hundreds of thousands of people
I've spoken to millions of people around
the world I could tell you this the
self-confident people I know whether
they are athletes school teachers
mechanics parents stay-at-home moms you
name it they have a pattern of keeping
promises they make to themselves the
groundwork of beginning to build
self-confidence is to begin to keep the
promises you make to you and that's why
it's important to begin to even make
small promise you're gonna get up at a
certain time in the morning not only do
it but then give yourself credit say I
did what I said I was gonna do if it's
in your diary your fitness don't just
eat the healthy foods go I'm doing what
I said I was going to do you begin to
build this reputation if you're
constantly being influenced and moved by
what other people think about you it
means there's a deficiency in what you
think about you and so the key is
not some you know and so esoteric like
belief system it's a pattern of keeping
the promises that you make to you that's
the groundwork of self-confidence for
sure and it is a pattern when I meet
people that lack confidence I think let
me serve you let's begin to keep the
promises you make to you you're so
worried about there's this addiction to
other people's approval in the world
right it's the greatest the greatest
addiction today
it used to be drugs before then it was
alcohol there's all these addictions sex
addiction is whatever the number one
addiction in the world today is the
addiction to other people's approval and
that's because we don't approve of
ourselves we or we don't feel a spirit a
universe a God that we believe in that
approves of us and so my confidence
comes from both my faith and him the
fact that I keep promises I make to
myself that's the groundwork of all
confidence rule number seven max out
your life see at the end of my life the
Lord's gonna go hey by the way this guy
over here this is the man you could have
been this is the person you were born to
be this would have been your dreams this
is where you would have gone what you
would have seen who you would have
helped what you would have changed this
would have been your book meet him my
dream in my life is that when I meet
that person we're not total strangers
you don't want to get to the end of your
life and that character is a total
stranger to you you know damn well
there's gonna be a funeral for you
someday at that funeral there's gonna be
a sense in a spirit of what you could
have become the woman the man you could
have become and every day those
decisions you're making to max out your
life are Jason that person see you know
what I want at the end of my life when I
meet him I want to be identical twins
Chad and Ed are gonna meet each other
someday and I'm gonna say hey man good
to see you been chasing you man easily
go I've been watching you you're exactly
like me man were identical twins you
maxed out your damn life congratulations
rule number eight get quiet I believe
everything has a vibration so everything
has an energy right and so that I have
without getting too complicated I have
to quiet myself because when I get quiet
I've vibrated a higher frequency and so
that I can tap into see the same thought
the same energy that made this ocean
that made the world that made you and I
I have access to that limitless
absolutely perfect thinking in mind and
so the only way that I get that is by
getting out of my home
way getting out of my own space getting
out of my own junk and so I access it
for me by getting quiet the key to my
life is that in the morning and I do it
in the morning it's nice now that I can
do with the ocean here I also live on a
lake is I just it doesn't take a long
time I just take 20 minutes and I access
it and I get quiet and the only way I
can access it is to get out of my head
it's like quiet and empty my mind and I
access the universe that's what I do
rule number nine hustle mom and dad work
my mom worked in the home raised four
kids my dad worked in a bank very
successful executive in a bank okay so
who you learning something from him
about being executive addressing no no I
learned about my dad real simple
hustle and busting ass so ha dad was up
before I was up in the morning out of
the house uh-huh my dad would get home
when it was dark I watched my dad bust
his tail watch my dad works Saturday
because he can add a couple of cocktails
ahead for a long time and it was
probably yeah the way why I was coming
home so late for a while but in my mind
and even after he became sober he's he
just like a lot of men of that
generation my dad just busted his damn
tail I think it was a lost art form with
younger guys today right my dad just
flat busted it now he busted it cuz he
was trying to provide limiting things
like food and shelter he never thought
about big things or dreams or getting
wealthy or having influence we just
wanted to survive and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is talk about your dreams so this
was my dream place to live all my life I
wanted to live in Laguna Beach
California in three arch Bay I wanted to
live in Coeur d'Alene Idaho and I want
to be able to play golf out in the
beautiful desert in Palm Desert I live
in those dream places and one of the
reasons I live there is because I talked
about my dream early in my life there's
power to just talking about just telling
people just putting in writing what your
dream is and so I'm curious do this for
me comment below right here and tell me
and tell the world where your dream
place to live is what's your dream place
to live I want to see your comments
below now I've got a really special
bonus clip with Edie talking about how
to always aim for more that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life in your
business so here we go question number
one
what's one promise you made to yourself
that you need to keep number two what
does a maxed out life look like to you
and number three what is your dream talk
about it below
top guys in our firm a few weeks ago one
of my favorite people probably the most
talented guys my company won't say who
he is cuz he might be watching this but
he said that to me goes I just wanted to
share with the world how amazing and
incredible my life is and bla bla bla
bla bla and I told him I said when I was
at your level I couldn't stomach it yeah
I couldn't handle it I can't live on
that kind of income I didn't want to
live my life like that I said it scares
me that you think somehow this is the
dream yeah
and then of course he kind of corrected
himself and backstopped but the fact is
I'm constantly deceiving myself that I
and I it's really I really do feel that
way like I really don't feel successful
I'm not I don't think I'm a failure
yeah but I do measure it up against the
highest version of me my highest
expression as opposed to what as opposed
to measuring yourself with other people
uh-huh that's the biggest thing people
do they're so obsessed with other people
that kills them they think about what
are they thinking about me what are they
gonna think about me what are they
saying
and then they measure themselves against
other people too and I don't think I
mean I've been around you yeah your your
powerhouse but neither one of us are
yeah I think your time is done at the
break neither one of us having super
crazy off-the-charts IQ yeah I sure know
you don't so I gotta talk to you for
sure you've been at a couple of daddy's
taking shots at obviously watch so they
know they see you know you need get
where you are because of some gift in
your life though man you know no but
it's the fact the oath of us didn't get
there because of some unbelievable
natural giftedness we have they just
wanna do success right there's so I
don't measure ourself against other
people because they got gifts that are
different about that yeah
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion can change the way
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
if you guys like this video check out
the one I did on the 5 morning routines
that will transform your life it's right
next to me I think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and they'll see you
there let's be honest how many y'all get
up you just get your day started you
don't have it written down you don't
have a strategy you don't have a real
plan